all right rylan yes ryland
tell me about your childhood you grew up
where uh i grew up in a small town uh
called cedrif texas i was born in a
smaller town called victoria texas
and population like less than 2 000
people just about
moved to corpus christi when i was a
little bit older
and yeah that's brings me i live in
houston texas currently though okay
and tell me about your family
so family i grew up with all my family
most people look at me and they believe
i was abandoned i don't have any family
or i'm not loved or anything i had my
whole family my whole family has been in
my life
grandma papa everybody's still alive
thank god so
very supportive very loving family a few
not so supportive group really christian
so i am i do believe in god people don't
think i do i look like a demon to most
people
now that you would look at me i look
like a vampire demon or whatever
somebody would want to call me but i
grew up christian so yeah so
pretty good childhood stuff pretty good
childhood yeah people don't think so
people
think about the stigmas of just
looking like this or even having tattoos
simply that
body body modification yeah body
modifications in general that you have
to be abandoned or not loved or hurt
but for me that wasn't it that the more
hurting in my life happened later
you finished high school i finished high
school i graduated high school at 2017
i'm about to be 23 in april
so yeah graduated high school after high
school you did what so after high school
i lived in corpus christi until high
school and then my dad agreed to let me
move in with him and he lives in houston
texas so at 18 he bought me my first car
and i moved in with him i had planned to
go to college he wanted me to do be a
nurse you're only gonna he's like
you're not going to do anything good
unless you go to college you have to go
to college to be successful that college
equals success equals the cookie cutter
life which i never wanted to live ever
ever in my life but that's what he told
me that's the only way i'll live or i'll
be homeless and i'll have nothing and
you showed me a photo of yourself yes i
did a couple years ago yes and you were
you looked very different i looked very
different nothing
not nothing on me really nothing at all
besides a few tattoos but so so
what i mean so where did your life go
after
you decided not to college so the thing
is i did go to college i my dad paid for
my first semester i went
i went for
less than a week
i went for less than a week and
the it's funny because i actually quit
because
you know they do the thing when you
first start what do you want to be after
college what do you want to be
i was in three two years for basics just
saying also how to do two years basics
and then three years nursing school like
what is this so
they went around the classroom
they asked everybody well what do you
want to be
everybody said a nurse like there's a
two kids said doctor lawyer and i was
like i'm literally about to sit here in
this class with kids and say i want to
be a nurse
i'm going to be put in this box in this
hamster wheel that i literally do not
want to live in i literally said
i i was gonna say a nurse but i i don't
wanna be i don't wanna be the same as
everybody i was like how do i drop out
and i dropped out like that moment never
went back had to hide it from my dad for
a whole semester he was so mad but
i couldn't do
it and how do you support yourself now
so now um
currently i'm a dancer and i do only
fans full time
both are
both are full-time jobs people think
it's just side it's just well that's not
real money it's nothing and i mean it's
it's supported me it almost came to a
point where
there was a point where my dad looked so
down on what i was doing like i i had to
kind of move out he didn't agree with it
he had a really toxic girlfriend at the
time so i couldn't live there anymore
she was kind of abusive and stuff just
mentally and they were just toxic so i
had to move out
and
he knew i was dancing he didn't like it
so
i got my first apartment in downtown
houston and
yeah it's pretty pricey but
but what i do is i don't know i like
what i do
my whole family knows what i do actually
my grandma my aunt everybody my grandma
shouted out my only fans sometimes too
you're clearly just the black sheep of
the family
yeah that's what they like to say i do
have two little sisters and
they're still young so i i don't want
them to follow in these footsteps so i
i'm not recommending this to anybody so
you're working at a strip club yeah yeah
i'm working at a strip club but it's
really hard for me right now because
they think having all this body
modification makes sense no they make me
cover up my face tattoos i have to cover
them up every night like i have to use
this really thick foundation on my skin
and every time i work i have to cover
them up and houston's just not really
good for dancing right now it's it's
really bad i don't know why
but and i try i want to try vegas i want
to try here in california but
it's something about the face tattoos
and that's so surprising because you
also have the eyes yeah i have my eyes
tattooed yeah people think their
contacts are in all contacts and i have
my teeth banged
so
yeah it
it's
it's sad because nowadays you would
think that just with the way the world
is like modifications are so common
they're so normal but strip clubs they
don't really allow that so i'm able to
express myself more and only fans like i
want to say i make more and only fans
than i do dancing
so yeah
what is it that got you
to do all this
tattooing and
piercing and so what it really was uh
how i said i had a good childhood i had
an amazing childhood love my family
amazing family but
i got into a toxic relationship from 18
to 21
and this man like destroyed my whole
mindset
everything
he
he took my phone he would beat me he
would hurt me and
he
i wasn't that person
the way i looked before
that every day was a daily reminder that
that's who he wanted me to be he wanted
my hair
short blonde cut like that he didn't
want me to have any tattoos he wanted me
to start removing my tattoos believe it
or not he made me get his name tattooed
but i cut it out but he said he would
leave me if i didn't tattoo his name and
then i did it and then he said it was a
test you're so stupid and then he made
me cover it up so
yeah and then he was trying to make me
start getting them removed and then
eventually i had a nanny job that's what
i was doing from 18 to 21
and then after 21 i started doing only
fans right on my 21st birthday i went to
the strip club and i started dancing and
only fans but before that i was a nanny
i was a nanny to two families i made
less than like 400 a week for my two
jobs i was giving all my money to him
for no reason he had two kids he said it
was for his kids but slowly a year or
two added up he had accumulated taken
over ten thousand dollars from me
and uh i couldn't take it anymore i went
to my breaking point he broke my phone i
had nothing my dad told me you have to
move out if you're gonna be with him and
i i hit my breaking point to where i had
to leave him
and then after that i got into the
dancing
and that and then it kind of just blew
up from there and i was able to support
myself but do you think all this
modification you've done is a reaction
to that relationship or so or is it
something you just always had in you i
want to say
it's almost i've always had it in me i
always said since i was a kid i would
want to be tattooed
i always wanted to be but i didn't know
what that meant to me i didn't know i
was going to do this to my face
interestingly enough i want to say i
really did my face after my own father
his business kind of crashed a little
bit love him to death but his business
crashed a little bit and he had to
borrow money from me
and at first i was like wow you need to
borrow money from the daughter you said
will never be nothing will never be
anything the way i look ugly trashy and
after that i was kind of like
society
doesn't mean you don't have to go to
college to win in life you don't they
want you to think that in school
but you don't but i don't knock college
anybody that wants to go to school go to
school but after that i was like i'm
gonna express myself however i want and
after that i started loving myself so
much after i did this really yeah
there was no self-love before i really
hated myself the way i used to look and
i would
why did my eyes almost a reason i would
look in my eyes and i would see my ex i
would just see
what he wanted me to be and i didn't
even want to look at my own eyes anymore
i just wanted them like gone in a way
and i discovered eyeball tattooing
eyeball injections
it's very dangerous but if you get it
done by the right person it's it's
pretty nice it doesn't really hurt or
anything
you talk about the eyes yeah the eyes it
doesn't it there's really no pain in it
it's very expensive it's perfect it's
permanent it's forever it's gonna last
the rest of my life you can't even get
it removed like the ones on your face if
you wanted to you could get them removed
yeah if i wanted to get my face tattoos
removed i definitely could uh the eyes
the eyes there forever can't change them
at all
interesting decisions you've made
interesting yeah people always ask will
i regret it that's one of the biggest
ask questions why regret it well i
regret it when i'm older
the thing is i don't want to be cliche
but i don't live life thinking i'm going
to regret things because you only live
once and i don't personally want to live
my life
looking
like everybody else on the street i
don't want to look like that i want
someone to look me at me and question me
why does she have that butterfly on her
head why does she do this
it's healthy to ask questions but if i'm
just someone that's just you just pass
by on the road i don't want to live life
like that
would you describe
the other
parts of your life as fairly
conventional or are you non-conformist
across the board
um
meaning like i mean like like the kind
of relationships you have the the
the life you know where you live the
lifestyle you lead so i honestly i want
to say i feel like i lived like a fairly
boring life uh i had drugs no drugs no
drugs involved in my life i did uh
synthetic marijuana one time when i was
14 years old i had a seizure in it
i had to go to the doctor and they
diagnosed me with bipolar depression
ptsd anxiety disorder they wanted to put
me on medications i took medications
when i was 16
but they made my body hot and it scared
me so after that i never took any
medication again so and do you have
bouts with depression anxiety anything
every day uh to this day i still have
chronic depression anxiety but
i i just live with it i have my cats
they help so much i don't look
towards drugs or alcohol because my mom
and my dad were both alcoholics my dad
had like five dwis heart but he owns a
business now he's great my mom she's in
a wheelchair now actually
she got really sick two years ago and
she lost her legs and it got her off the
alcohol really so she doesn't really
drink anymore but i told myself i didn't
want to end up like that ever
and just i i couldn't become an
alcoholic or a drug addict so people
wouldn't think but i'm pretty i'm pretty
straight edge and as far as
relationships i kind of like swore off
relationships now um the last two i was
in one ten thousand dollars from me the
other wanted money for me or they didn't
want to be with me anymore because they
think i got it like that and
that's not what you should be like in a
relationship so
are you happier now than you were before
you did all this stuff definitely 100
more happier but depression doesn't care
if you change your looks it doesn't care
if you have money doesn't care where you
live it'll follow you
as long as it wants to so it's a battle
but
i have my little baby cats so
do you have any regrets in your life
you're you're how old you you're 22 22.
so regrets oh my gosh
i want to say it was
you know it's almost like i can't say i
regret anything because i wouldn't be
where i'm at
i would not be where i'm at right now do
i regret
maybe
smoking fake weed when i was 14 and
getting all these symptoms from it and
being diagnosed with all this traumatic
stuff yes but i i wouldn't i wouldn't be
where i am in my life if i didn't do
everything i've done
up to now and i believe where i'm at is
the best place i can be in my life right
now
and you you don't
you wouldn't consider all these things
you're doing as self-destruct many
people would watch this video and say oh
this girl's self-destruction yes they
would say that uh no i
people say it's self-destructive they
say you don't love yourself
and they say what happens when you get
older and i'm like what do you mean
we're all gonna get older you're gonna
have wrinkles i'm gonna have wrinkles
but i'm gonna look cool and have
wrinkles like what you're gonna you know
it's
it's pure self-love there's no
destruction in this at all i did this
because i love myself because
it's a part of me now and i'll continue
to get tattoos i'm not done i'm gonna
cover my whole body done with my face
for sure but i have many more to get
is it is it some kind of
i'm trying to break it down as to what
what motivates you to do it is it a
call for like
attention or just to be different or
so misunderstood definitely not a call
for attention it's it's for myself
almost because to me tattoos are so
painful they're the most painful things
you'll ever get to me honestly
it's almost like an accomplishment after
i do them and
i just don't like seeing a body that i
can see on the street a million times
over i don't want to be copy and pasted
in any form of my life
and that's kind of how i feel like we
all come out it might sound dumb to some
people but it's like we all come out
looking the same i don't want to look
like that at all
it's been a couple years now that you've
started doing this yeah only two years
that i've completed basically the whole
transformation that i've really wanted
to complete yeah you've done a lot yeah
i did my face like a week ago i just did
the other side of my face like a week
ago i did this about a week ago and then
i just got a little sphinx in my palm
like three days ago
so i just sometimes i just wake up and
i'm like i want to tattoo like my tattoo
artist i told her one day i woke up and
i was like i want you to tattoo my face
and i don't care what it is and she just
tattooed this huge sword on my face
so yeah
how have you changed from just from the
modifications you've done
in what way i mean like i'm sure you get
different reactions from people i'm sure
that
so it affects your life in some way yes
my
my grandma i love her to death but she's
so christian she's very christian and
bless her heart but she are are you
testing the
the conformity of everyone around you
i imagine houston must be uh
fairly so interestingly
interestingly
people aren't very open there uh i
go into some place someone notices me
someone stares at me for a long time and
i almost like it because i want people
to almost be offended i don't know why
but because it's like you shouldn't be
offended you shouldn't judge a book by
its cover actually i had an instance the
other day i was in a cvs
a woman she was on the phone with her
friend i was minding my business just i
don't even know what i was getting she
was on the phone with her friend and she
said there is this girl standing right
next to me and she looks like the
ugliest demon i've ever seen like this
girl looks like a straight up ugly demon
and i said excuse you
i said what are you talking about and
she was like you know you're going to go
to hell like why would you do that to
yourself you look like a demon and i
said ma'am god says thou shall not judge
i said you're going to see hell way
before i do.
so
like i love that because
you can't judge somebody you just can't
judge them
you really can't you don't know what's
behind this like people don't really
know
that behind this like there is a lot of
pain and hurt
but
i did this because i love myself
so they're just judging the outside
they're not judging my soul which is
what really counts
what are you afraid of
oh
what am i afraid of
i used to say monsters i used to be
monsters i to this day i still don't
sleep in my bedroom i'm scared of things
i don't i don't know i
people are like well you look like the
monster and i'm like i get that but i'm
scared of people
people are some people are the scariest
things ever and that relationship kind
of reinforced them and that's actually
kind of why i got the butterflies i have
a lot of butterflies i'm going to
continue to get butterflies because
people are some of the most so what it
is is butterflies they're so beautiful
they're so pretty i love looking at
butterflies we have butterfly museums in
houston love those things but what
people don't really know is that
their anatomy on the inside what they
really are they're really gross they
they eat vomit they eat spit they eat
each other after they mate there's a
bunch of other things about them that's
just really weird like they die after
like a few days or a week and
i kind of look at people like
butterflies because on the outside they
can look so beautiful and so pretty
but on the inside
it can be some of the ugliest people in
the world and you wouldn't know monsters
so
you're
trying to be the opposite of that
exactly exactly it's almost like i look
like the monster on the outside
and on the inside i just i'm the
beautiful butterfly
that's great
are you happy is this like the happiest
point of your life right now i would say
right now i'm at the happiest point in
my life but i'm also at the lowest point
um
i struggle very bad with depression it's
so bad uh
it's hard to even wake up some days so
it's it's like one of those things i
have everything i could ever want i have
an apartment i have beautiful cats i
just bought a new car
i have a loving family but it's like
depression doesn't care
i still don't look forward to things i'm
not happy some days i am i have bipolar
depression i have bipolar disorder some
days i'm so up here and then the next
day i'm down here
so but i would say right now in my life
this is exactly where i need to be so
that's why i'm happy yeah does
doing sex work the only fans on the
stripping does that
yeah that could undermine
a woman's happiness yeah so
i know i can't do it forever and there
are days i wake up and i'm crying my
eyes out because i'm just so depressed
i'm so sad and i have no idea why and a
guy
wants a video of me doing explicit
things and it's like
he'll pay me a hundred dollars for the
video or whatever you know and it's just
like i i almost have to be a sexual
being 24 7. because that's what it is
that's my job if i'm not i'm not gonna
make money does that get to you
a lot because it made me realize like
another thing why i wouldn't even really
want to be in relationships there's
so many
married men on my stuff so many people
that ask me oh how much for this how
much for that and it it's it's degrading
but i i asked for it in a way i
but i'm successful at it if i wasn't
successful at it i wouldn't be doing it
so it is
a really good thing but there's also so
many down parts about it even with
dancing because it's like i have to go
and actually be touched by people and
sometimes not make a dollar and then i
have to go home and be 24 7
by messages 24 7 on my own fans and i
have to respond because they pay me
so
do i want to do it forever no
but i'm saving up as much as i can and
i'm gonna hopefully figure out before
i'm 25 what i'm going to do
maybe invest maybe i will never conform
to a regular job though i'll never do
that do you long for a
a relationship with somebody who just
accepts you and loves you as you are
you know i do actually i really do
uh i just kind of another really bad
relationship about two months ago he
just
he's 34 years old but he literally stole
my xbox and he
told me if i wouldn't give him money he
wasn't going to stay with me so
it's really sad like i feel like
i'll never find it almost i feel like
it's just a different world we live in
now and even if they do
i just don't feel like some people are
very committed and want to be with one
person forever but i do
hope to be loved in the future by
somebody do you have friends
small group i want to say i have one or
two friends and i need that
huh that's all you need though it's all
you need it's all you need i have my
family i don't what i look at friends is
like if we can't benefit each other and
be on the same level
or above me then
why are we in each other's lives i don't
party i don't go out i don't drink i
don't do any of that stuff so i would
rather have someone that uplifts me that
can help me reach higher goals in life
than people that are just below me and
have nothing to really offer me so do
your friends understand you or get you
yeah yeah the ones that are really in my
life like they're they're there always
but
are they alternative like you like
yourself or no they're kind of in the
scene but not really like me they're
just some
like honestly it's literally two people
it's only two yeah that's okay though
yeah so it's like nothing
yeah it's it's but besides that family
so it's like if they're
if they're squares basically or look
like that yeah but they understand you
yeah oh yeah it's beautiful just my
whole family too they all know crazy
tattoos or anything but
they love me and they go by god says
don't judge so i'll never judge you
because they know my heart they know the
person i am
so yeah so there was nothing in your
childhood that really no trauma that may
have led to something like this
so i think i almost forgot to mention um
i'm not going to really mention any
names or anything but when i was younger
there was an app called seeking
arrangements i'm sure it's still around
but
you can get like sugar daddies and
things like that so when i was in high
school
i kind of wanted to like help my family
out and stuff a little bit
so
i would go on dates at 16 17 years old
because i was able to lie on the app and
i would do these dates for money uh 16
17 years old skipping school high school
and um
these are sexual favors
i would say something like that yeah
this is something you did on your own or
um it was or somebody led you into it so
it was more on my own but
influenced that kind of like
it's not not bad to do it no one was
really because i kind of kept it from
most my family but some people knew and
wasn't really let out of it to where you
know
i was like
let out of it because no one was really
strict strict on me so i kind of skipped
school a lot and i would do these things
and make the money fast money and i
think that's also kind of why i'm like
so desensitized to like the sex industry
now because i kind of did it at a
younger age and i did it kind of up
until i was 18 and then i got into the
bad relationship
you know fast money quick money but
it's gone now like
so fast money like that
it wasn't worth it um did it mess with
my mental health a little bit yeah in a
way was it a little traumatic yeah
uh i just try to grow from it now
for sure because it was when i think
about it like now i'm like oh my gosh i
was 16
doing that with like doctors and lawyers
and i was literally skipping school
getting truancy like
and you know
i mean i was taking care of my little
sisters too i would help them out so
it was like
it was good money but
i i had to stop after a while but i
wouldn't say it's the leading factor to
why i did all this to myself i would say
it's almost something that kind of gave
me thick skin and made me a stronger
person to not be so weak
so i would say your mom was an alcoholic
your dad was too yeah so my mom having
both parents as alcoholics probably so
my mom was an alcoholic dad was an
alcoholic my dad traveled a lot he
wasn't in my life as much he's me and my
dad are really close now my dad
yeah my dad and my mom divorced when i
was one
they just couldn't do it and then my mom
has two other daughters with two
different men one of them died one of my
sister's dads died and then i currently
have a stepdad now and he takes care of
them as of now
so you're the oldest i'm the oldest yeah
i have a 19 year old sister and a 14
year old sister and i try to help my 19
year old sister out as much as my as
much as i can she's like my daughter
because
uh she's just
i don't want her to go on a bad path so
i try to help her out as much as i can
now just try to like lead her in the
right ways not to what i'm doing but
just in a better path than me
you must get crazy interactions with
people encounters with people right so i
would say i do um mostly online sure i
do but at the club for sure um
people with a club
it it's really gross sometimes like we
have five dollar tuesdays it's like five
dollar dances and
you know a 20 dance fully nude like we
do
everything and
oh my gosh these men i i really
it just it's really gross like so i'll
be giving a dance and they'll literally
try to stick their tongue out and
put it all up in my private parts and i
i literally always call them out and i'm
like you know i could have a disease
right like you don't know who i am and
they get so scared
they get so scared and i just think it's
so funny like
these people like even when i'm on stage
dancing they will try to straight up
stick their fingers all in your crevices
and
i'm just like what and then i have to
still go home and deal with people
wanting videos of me like
putting multiple things and doing all
these crazy things and it's like
it's a different life it's a different
life because i feel like it's almost
like
i'm not like this crazy sexual being
like i'm really not like on the inside i
really i just want love like if i was
with someone i really just want love and
cuddles i'm not all about this crazy
stuff but people look at me and think oh
i'm so extreme i must love all this
insane stuff but i don't so i have to
fake it like every day it's acting i'm a
good actor it's almost like what you
what you've done to your body and all
that is just a statement against
judgment exactly exactly
and our preconceived ideas about each
other exactly that's what it is
what has all this taught you
everything you're going through
everything you've been through
about life
what have you learned
what have i learned
what has this taught me
that
one
it's cliche but don't ever judge
somebody don't ever don't ever judge
somebody don't ever tell somebody they
can't be something
don't don't sit there and say because
you look one way you can't do something
because i've more than proved
that i can do anything and be anything
even looking like this
so i say peace and love every day i i
say to everybody i talk it i speak it
into existence i don't speak negativity
into the world i don't talk hate on
anybody
so i would say we all just need to be
kind to one another and everyone just
needs to be nice because this world can
be so cruel
so i would just say just
it's all love in this world and that's
what we should all be even if i look
crazy and like a monster or whatever i'm
all about love and i think judgment
is an interesting thing because it
certainly if you read the comments on
a lot of the videos on this channel
you'll
you can see everyone loves to judge they
seem to be addicted to it i believe it's
an addiction yeah yeah for sure it's
something that somehow it makes us feel
better about ourselves or something it's
an attempt to make us feel better about
ourselves i had a whole lot put someone
else down yeah i had a whole tick tock
it got deleted tick tock is stupid to me
but i had almost a million followers on
it every single day people were saying
oh your father must not love you oh your
mother must not love you and i would
pull my dad into the video with me and
i'd be like here's my dad he loves me
people would say the nastiest things
like oh you must be forcing your family
to do videos with you because they hate
you like people have said things to
where my grandma's watching those videos
and she's crying for me because people
are so hateful and i'm like for what why
like are you not happy with yourself
because because i don't care about
judgment because it's just a reflection
of them yeah that's how i say yeah i
have no reason to judge anybody and i
never have and i never will hate on
anybody because i love myself so i have
i believe
that when you're making a judgment about
somebody else it's really a reflection
of something about yourself that you
don't even understand you don't even see
it is it's exactly there's something
about yourself that
yeah like somebody will watch your video
or
or someone else that i interview and
there'll be something about that that
interviewee that will take you off
exactly and you're gonna make a judgment
to knock them down or criticize them in
some way but if you really broke all
that down
there's something about yourself that
you're not looking at exactly that you
need to look at and i look at it at
people get mad at things they don't
understand
a lot or or there's something about a
person that will remind them of
something in themselves that they don't
like so they'll knock that down exactly
exactly
all right thank you so much for
talking with me and uh
i wish you the best of luck with
whatever you're doing from here thank
you so much mark stay happy
thank you very much bye
you